I think America South is a very
difficult place to comprehend if you
don't come from the south I think
there's a familiarity that exists in the
south between white and black people
that northerners don't really understand
and in that regard James Brown was much
more southerner than he was a black man
because there's a kind of everyone stays
in their lane kind of mentality between
whites and blacks in the south
especially during James Brown's ehre
that we in the North just don't
understand I think part of it is they
accept each other's sins accept each
other's dirty laundry they don't make
any comment about it everybody has
problems they all worship the same God
but there are certain lines you don't
cross everybody knows their place it's a
you know very ordered society and you
should try this you know maintain the
kind of dignity and honor and trust that
is part of the American South that which
which in one way makes it great and then
one makes it one way makes it tragic you
know and I don't think you can
understand James Brown without
understanding at least having a cursory
understanding of America South because
it's a place where people are extremely
kind extremely dignified will give you
their last quarter and trust you on on a
handshake
but if you betray that trust their
journey with you is pretty much over and
then if you you know you come at them
wrong after that then you you know you
liable to spend you know the rest of
your life babbling into therapy or
sipping your food through a straw
because southerners have a great deal of
power you have to remember the South
beat the the the Confederate Army beat
the Union Army three years straight with
and they were outgunned and out you know
I mean it's true they were outgunned and
they
out man then they had that backs up
about people telling them what to do and
I don't think anyone knows southerners
as well as the blacks who walk among
them and one of those was James Brown
that's why I say you can't understand
him without understanding the land that
produced him which is a good place full
of good people with some pretty you know
pretty bad lawyers was a pretty good
lawyers depending on who you know I was
so whose side you're on James Brennan
left everything he had his entire estate
his likeness his music his performances
publishing everything his entire wealth
to a fund to educate poor black and
white children in South Carolina in
Georgia he was very specific about that
poor children of all types and this guy
was a victim of racism his entire life
but he was very he was he he operated
with the belief that we are all we have
to come together as you know as American
people that was in 2006 and ten years
not a single kid has been educated not a
single penny of that to my knowledge has
reached a single kid it's a tied up in
lawsuits you know 48 lawsuits four
thousand pages of testimony 90 attorneys
most of whom never even knew James Brown
butts because it was just some of his
children and his last wife if shindy was
his wife and the state of South Carolina
have come together to create this
cacophony of lawsuits whereby lawyers
just sue each other and dip into his
estate to pay each other and it's all
guided by a trustee that was appointed
by the state so the guy who created soul
music and really is probably the biggest
creator of the American pop musical
sound his music is being administered by
the state of South Carolina which is not
known to be a play
where they're very gentle and kind when
it comes to african-american life so I
don't believe that would happen if his
name was Elvis Presley with John Lennon